[Music]
the chalkboard gag in the intro to the
simpsons has become an iconic sight in
tv comedy
and over the years bart simpson has
written a whole heap of words on that
chalkboard
from controversial political statements
to in-jokes to colorful innuendos these
are bart's most savage
chalkboard jokes it's not easy being a
teacher
even putting aside the low pay and awful
working conditions you've sometimes got
to deal with students like bart simpson
after all bart's penchant for stirring
up trouble is the reason why he's
perpetually writing lines in the first
place
time and again he's ruthlessly attacked
the faculty of springfield elementary
school with smart mouth remarks devious
pranks and wisecracks
bart's teacher edna krabappel has
especially suffered at bart's hands as
seen in his rather questionable remarks
concerning her appearance in the intro
for the episode the ziff who came to
dinner
other bart chalkboard notes regarding
mrs krabappel include i will not call my
teacher hotcakes
i will not mock mrs dumbface and i will
not hide the teacher's prozac
bart has even remarked on mrs
krabappel's love life such as when he
was forced to admit that teacher was not
dumped it was mutual and over 40 and
single is not funny
ouch during the simpsons time on
television the show has become infamous
for predicting the future
it mocked the idea of using chemicals
found in gym mats as hidden fillers and
processed foods all the way back in 1995
which grossly enough turned out to be
true in 2014
homer simpson even got pretty close to
guessing the weight of the recently
discovered higgs boson particle in
1998's the wizard of evergreen terrace
but the simpsons made one of its most
notorious predictions to date in bart to
the future which originally aired in
2000
the episode takes place in the year 2030
when lisa has just become
president of the united states and is
facing some economic difficulties thanks
to the previous commander-in-chief
as you know we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from president trump
shortly after trump's election to the
presidency the show referenced its own
uncanny prediction with the chalkboard
gag in which bart writes being right
sucks many of bart's chalkboard quotes
are peppered with evocative innuendos
and playful puns
he apparently couldn't stop talking
about the 12-inch pianist
in marge be not proud and makes a nod to
sir mix-a-lot when he notes
sherry does not got back in wild bart's
can't be broken
among some of his more colorful
innuendos you've got bart vowing not to
hang donuts on his person
promising not to make fun of cupid's
dink and acknowledging that
pork is not a verb bart also shares some
of his rejected words of wisdom in 101
mitigations
when he is seen writing chili fries do
not go in like a lamb
and out like a lion but things get taken
to the next level during the opening
sequence for the episode pray anything
in which bart scribbles out spongebob is
not a contraceptive
gotta give the kid credit for creativity
don't you
bart certainly gets up to his fair share
of shenanigans and if the show's
chalkboard gags are anything to go by
they don't all happen on screen
over the years some of bart's
prank-based chalkboards have included i
will not yell fire in a crowded
classroom
i will not yell she's dead during roll
call and the pledge of allegiance does
not end with hale satan
he apparently harassed a blind person by
promising to return the seeing eye dog
in whacking day
and vowed he wouldn't put hot sauce in
the cpr dummy at the start of father
knows worst
bart has also expressed a rather more
worrying side to his classroom antics
including writing five days is not too
long to wait for a gun
non-flammable is not a challenge and
hooligan is not a profession
one of bart's most notable moments of
chalkboard mischief hails from the
episode
doe canada bart writes ha-ha on the
blackboard
then hits it which rotates to reveal
nelson tape to the other side
who's laughing now the writers on the
simpsons are no strangers to getting
meta and this
is usually most noticeable during the
show's opening sequences
and of course the chalkboard gags for
example there's the time when bart cut
corners while writing i will not cut
corners by
only writing the line out six times and
filling out the remaining lines with
ditto quotation marks
he also slyly remarks this punishment is
not boring and pointless in camp crusty
and writes i'm sorry i broke the
blackboard on a whiteboard in black eyed
please
in reference to how critics described
south park when it first aired bart
writes i'm not charlie brown on acid
in the blunder years he also poked fun
at the simpsons itself by writing i will
not celebrate meaningless milestones
when the show was airing its 100th
episode
after butterfinger canceled their
simpsons ad campaign because the brand
had been the butt of some of the show's
jokes bart responded by writing i will
not bite the hand that feeds me
butterfingers
then when the simpsons hit the big
screen and got their own movie in 2007
bart promised not to illegally download
this movie in its intro
he also joked that he will never win an
emmy in homer's barbershop quartet
even though by that point the show had
already won nine
throughout 2020 the united states and
the rest of the world faced the first
waves of the kovit 19 pandemic
seemingly overnight countless people
found themselves struggling to adapt to
a new way of life
in an attempt to stem the tide many
offices went virtual
and so did schools parents everywhere
suddenly found themselves trying to help
their children navigate
online classrooms and curricula and from
the looks of it not even the simpsons
were immune to the chaos of the
coronavirus pandemic
as a way to honor these drastic changes
the simpsons modified its chalkboard gag
for an episode that aired on april 19th
2020. during the intro to the incredible
lightness of being a baby bart's
classroom is empty and a single line on
the board reads
school online a poignant nod to the
dramatic events that would have
resonated with students parents and
teachers everywhere
ralph wiggum is one of the simpsons
stranger and most endearing characters
sure he's a perfectly sweet little boy
but he's also incredibly odd and
about as brainless as you can get that's
where i saw the leprechaun
right a leprechaun he told me to burn
things
of course bart is well aware of ralph's
many quirks and is constantly teasing
him for it even during the show's
chalkboard gags
in the intro to fear of flying bart
writes ralph won't morph if you squeeze
him hard enough
a reference to the color morphing stress
balls that were popular at the time the
show aired
one of bart's more savage notes
concerning his odd classmate can be seen
in apocalypse cow
in which he writes a person's a person
no matter how ralph
class pets are a fun way to reinforce
the lessons they're taught in school
as well as help students experience the
responsibility of taking care of a small
life
in fact studies have also shown that
pets in the classroom have positive
impacts on student behavior
enhanced social interaction and student
attitudes
not that you'd know it looking at bart
those poor
poor hamsters there have been a handful
of class hamsters featured on the
simpsons over the years
including nibbles the hamster who
bravely helped save those trapped inside
the school in skinner's sense of snow
and even made it to space and back in
she of little faith
regardless of their heroism however bart
has relentlessly mocked his class
hamsters during the show's chalkboard
gags
during the intro to homer the whopper
bart writes the class hamster isn't just
sleeping
and in day of the jack and apes he notes
the hamster did not have a full life
yikes get in that ball and run for the
hills little hamster
godspeed nibbles godspeed
nuts being a parent is a massive
blessing but it can also be incredibly
frustrating and having a kid like bart
must make it even harder to exercise
discipline still that doesn't exactly
excuse homer's particular approach to
parenting
that is strangling bart whenever he
loses his patience
luckily this is just a cartoon which
generally makes homer's strangulations
more humorous than horrific
still this is one aspect of the show
that hasn't aged too well over the last
30 years and even though it's set in the
context of the show's off-the-wall humor
it can still be a tough pill to swallow
and this problem is eloquently touched
upon during the chalkboard gag for frank
gets testy in which homer can be seen
writing strangling
is not an effective parenting tool as a
smug bart watches on
during the show's time on television the
simpsons has stirred up plenty of
controversy surrounding religion
one obvious example of this is ned
flanders who is a constant target for
jokes about christianity
but one of the more subtle ways the show
has poked fun at religion over various
episodes
is through the use of barch chalkboard
quotes in the intro to
the burns and the bees bart writes jesus
is not mad his birthday is on christmas
and
in reality bites he notes there was no
roman god named farticus
but one of his darkest and funniest
remarks comes during the intro to dark
knight court in which bart writes
jesus's last words were not tgif
in a world like the simpsons mothers are
the cornerstones of their households and
that goes doubly for marge simpson
mom you're always trying to give me
potatoes what is it with you
i just think they're neat but even
though marge loves bart unconditionally
he can definitely make things difficult
at times just take his attitude to
mother's day for example
over the years bart has lambasted that
particular holiday by writing things
such as today is not mothra's day
eating my vegetables is not a mother's
day present and dirty clothes are not a
mother's day gift
in the intro to homer scissorhands he
even writes i do not deserve a mother's
day gift for being one badass mother
but hey maybe it's not all that bad
during the intro to ned and edna's blend
in one of his more lucid moments bart
writes call your mother during the
commercials
during the 25th season of the simpsons
executive producer
al jean dropped a massive bombshell on
fans that in the near future they'd be
killing off a major character
the writers had initially planned for
the death to take place later that
season
but in the end they had to delay it
until the show's 26th season
this delay only stirred the public's
interest that much more and for months
simpsons fans were left in a state of
deep suspense furious speculation and
rumors circulated across the
internet over who exactly the unlucky
soul would be
many suspected krusty the clown as being
the doomed character
but when the episode clown in the dumps
finally did air it turned out his father
rabbi hyman krastovski was the
long-hinted character who
would ultimately pass away playing up to
fans speculation about the long-awaited
episode the show opens with an equally
memorable chalkboard gag
in his typical ruthless fashion bart
rights spoiler alert unfortunately my
dad doesn't die
another major simpsons character who
passed away on the show is bart's
teacher edna krabappel
during season 25 the actor who voiced
the character marcia wallace passed away
as a humble way of paying respect to
wallace's memory bart's normally savage
tone was tamed for the chalkboard gag
opening the episode following wallace's
passing
in four regrettings and a funeral a
solemn looking bart
writes just one line on the chalkboard
we'll really miss you mrs k
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you